vanessa bryant is calling out
meek mill over that lyric in his new
song
and if i ever lack i'm going out with my
child
on monday bryant took to her instagram
story to slam the lyrics in mill's elite
track
don't worry which referred to her late
husband
kobe bryant tell me that she let me but
she never show me
the 38 year old orange county native
shut that lyric down
writing dear meek mill i find this line
to be extremely insensitive and
disrespectful
period i am not familiar with any of
your music
but i believe you can do better than
this if you are a fan
fine there's a better way to show your
admiration for my husband
this lacks respect and tact our
responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a leg up on tuesday
the rapper explained on twitter that he
had spoken to bryant and
expressed he's sorry quote nothing i say
on my page directed to an internet viral
moment or the family of a grieving woman
if you care about someone grieving
change the subject
last week when the song first leaked the
33 year old rapper clapped back at
critics who slammed the lyric
tweeting quote somebody promo a
narrative and y'all follow it
y'all internet antics cannot stop me
like zombieland or something lol but
mill's response to that heat
seemed to get more intense following
bryant's post
shortly after she shared that message on
instagram
mill tweeted quote i'm going back savage
in the
feelings it's not clear if the tweet was
directed at bryant
but many fans on social media assumed it
was
given the timing and his reaction
she's amazing i was there helping you
know
doing everything i possibly can to make
the process easier for my wife
and uh you know but ultimately
you know she did all the work i was just
there just trying to help her out
the late nba star and his 13 year old
daughter gianna
died along with six other passengers and
the pilot
in a tragic helicopter crash on january
26
2020 in calabasas california
a source previously told et that bryant
and the three other daughters she shares
with kobe
18 year old natalia four-year-old bianca
and one-year-old capri
have been extremely thankful for their
friends and family
who have helped them cope with the
tragedy
you